hey everyone it's lucy here as you can
see today i have a very special guest
with me on the show
and as you can see from the title of
this video london actually passed 12
eight of your certifications in 12
months london is an internet aws and
throughout his internship he was able to
consistently
prepare for aws certifications and so
today we're going to be talking about
all things related to certifications how
to pass
different ones and how to maintain the
motivation to study for these
certifications
we're going to get started off by glenda
introducing himself so hey glendon how
are you today
hey lucy thank you so much for having me
on your channel hi everyone
i'm glendon and i'm currently in my
final year of college
based in singapore so i go to nyang
technological university
or ntu and i'm pursuing a bachelor's of
computer science
and a master's of science in technology
management
as mentioned by lucy earlier i'm
currently on my second internship with
amazon web services
or aws with my current role as a
prototyping engineer
within the asean prototyping team in the
past one year at aws
i have set forth and passed all 12 aws
certifications
nice yeah that's honestly such an
impressive achievement and it's
very very rare for people to you know
pass all 12 certifications in the first
place
um but for you to pass you know all 12
in um 12 months that's
really impressive so can you start by
telling us a bit about you know your
certification journey
when did you prepare and pass the first
certification
and all the way into the uh final one
yeah for sure
so my my journey began when i first
joined
aws as a children's architect intern
during my third year of college
and that was last year in 2020 so back
then
i was really new to the cloud and did
not have any experience working with any
cloud providers
and much less developing on them on top
of that it turned out that my internship
project
set at the intersection between many aws
services
when i first sat down with my manager on
my project brief
i recall hearing many aws services being
thrown around
and i was scrambling to write them down
so that i can read up on them
afterwards it was really overwhelming
and i didn't know where to begin
it was then a clique recommended for me
to look at the aws
cloud practitioner certification to get
a good high level overview
of the array of the aws products and
offerings
so i went through the process of
studying for the certification
as a ramp up for my internship and felt
that it provided me with a very good
structure
and curriculum of what i needed to know
so
after sitting for the cloud practitioner
certification the scope of my project
at work got more technical and i
gradually felt that it would make a lot
more sense
for me to go for the certification that
was reflected on my job title
and that was the solutions architect
associate level certification
after the second certification i
realized i've built a pretty good
routine of incorporating a couple of
hours studying each day
into my schedule and decided to keep
going for it
for the duration of my internship also i
have to provide a disclaimer
that as i was working at aws during this
period of time
i was able to expense the course of the
certification
as an incentive for employees to hone
their skill sets
this is a huge factor for me as going
for those technical certifications
in cheap and this removes the financial
investment that i have to consider
as i didn't have any experience with aws
trial
or any cloud experience for that matter
i approach the certifications
incrementally
starting from the foundation and
certifications followed by the associate
level certifications
and finally the professional level and
specialty certifications
i have also intentionally chose to go
for the certification
that has direct relevance to my project
at work
so for example a project at work
required me to spend hours and hours
building ai ml projects on aws shmaker
i then took the opportunity to study for
the aws machine learning specialty
certification
at the same time to serve as a great
complement
i observed that the theoretical
knowledge from studying for the
certification
would help me enhance my understanding
at work and at the same time
my hands-on experience from building
projects would help me navigate those
challenging questions during the exam
so taking a high-level overview of my
journey i passed my first aws
certification
the cloud practitioner certification on
14 july last year
and i passed my final aws certification
the advanced networking specialty
certification
on 2nd june this year that brings me to
about 11 to 12 months
for my entire club journey nice 11 to 12
months wow
so yeah there was so much packed in that
answer and one thing that really stood
out to me was that
you decided to take every certification
based on
what you were sort of doing as an intern
so that way you can sort of directly
apply what you've learned in the
certification
to your role as an intern and yeah i
think definitely as an intern it does
motivate us to
be able to like study for these
certifications because sometimes we can
expense them as well so
yeah that's honestly a benefit for us um
and so my next question is
you know with each of these
certifications you gave us like a really
good high level
understanding of your journey and the
sort of roadmap that you took so i guess
for every single certification
specifically
how do you typically break down each one
in terms of the way you approach them
so what tips do you have for students
when they're first starting out on the
cloud journey let's say they're doing
their
associate solutions architect exam or
their
cloud practitioner exam how would you
recommend approaching these sort of
exams
right yeah that's a good question so
before i talk about my approach to
tackling or preparing for aw
certification i'd like to first share
about a mental model that i have
surrounding the certification process
so um it's a working thesis but i
believe that there are two key metrics
that one can and should optimize for
what embarking on their certification
journey
a candidate can either number one
optimize for learning the content
oh number two optimize for passing the
exam
and i really believe that a healthy
blend of both is
ideal which serves as a framework for my
approach
to preparing for an aws certification at
this point
i will usually follow a three-stage
process when preparing for a new
certification
and they are number one scoping the
subject
number two testing yourself and number
three
diving deep and clarify it then clarify
so for number one of scoping the subject
i will usually start by looking up the
exam guide for the certification
just to get a sense and scope of the
curriculum of the exam for aws
certifications
i would also recommend looking at the a
cloud guru learning videos
as they provide a really good high level
overview of the subject in question
however as stated in many forums and
youtube videos
simply by watching their videos will not
be sufficient to pass the exam
at this stage i will simply focus on
getting a good high level understanding
of the different topics and domains
before moving to the next stage
in stage 2 of testing yourself i will
now look into practice exams
provided by different vendors like a
club group
wrist labs and udemy and will attempt to
complete them
slowly over a period of time so when
attempting practice questions
i tend to let the questions guide me to
further read up on the different domains
if i transform a question that i'm
unsure about i would then look into
other learning resources
such as the ews documentation white
papers
and even tutorials on youtube in search
for the answer
and as you can imagine this iterative
process is going to take a long long
time
and it's going to be really painful but
i found that this method
would allow the candidate to not only
pass the exam
but also dive deep into actually
understanding the content
in order to reap the benefits from
getting the certification
nice that's a really good learning
suggestion because you know it's not
just about
passing the exam but it's also about
making sure you learn
and retain all that relevant information
along the way
so that's a really good approach so my
next question
is were there any challenges that you
faced along the way
when studying for certifications it
seems like you know user seamlessly
passed
auto certifications but i'm sure you
have a lot of tips and takeaways from
this whole journey that you can really
share with students
so that students can be aware of these
potential challenges and also
maybe know what to do if they also face
a similar challenge
yeah for sure um looking back
in my past one year i i've observed that
my biggest challenge
faced during this journey would have to
be the periodic deeps of motivation
where i felt really drained and burned
out from studying for the certifications
as it got really repetitive so
referencing the earlier framework that i
mentioned
whenever you are doing an exam question
that you don't know
you will then have to spend about 30
minutes to an hour looking at the answer
and understanding you know what what
what's exactly happening behind that
question
before moving towards the next question
and this process
doesn't do very well for morale if you
you know go through a series of 10 to 20
questions that you totally have no idea
about
and it was especially bad during busy
periods at work
where i felt really exhausted just from
work and had to put in a couple of hours
to study afterwards
i remember during those times i would
usually try my best to power through
but it got really bad i would say about
six months into my journey
and i had to take an entire month to
rest and recuperate from taking
certification
before coming back to it so i i guess
the learning point that
i have for this is it really helps if
you have
an actual intention and and go for the
certification
so as mentioned earlier when i was doing
the aws machine learning specialist
certification
i felt like it had direct impact and
relevance to my work
so studying for it felt slightly
more fuss-free because the purpose was
very clear to me
whereas when i was attempting other
certifications such as the advanced
networking certification
when it didn't have any direct impact on
my day-to-day work
it felt a lot more you know
uncomfortable and a lot more dreadful
going through that process
thanks so much for sharing that it's so
interesting to hear because
i that's honestly like the biggest
challenge that i faced as well
with motivation because sometimes you
know you do see the benefits of getting
aws certified there are quite a few
benefits that we'll go into later on as
well
um but motivation is a huge component
and it's you know sometimes when you do
have to take that one month break
yeah definitely recommend students take
that so that you can
you know take a break and keep powering
through your certifications when you
feel recharged and relaxed
so yeah and also as you mentioned kind
of knowing your why so why you're
preparing for exam
if it's relevant to your job or maybe
you're looking to
gain a new job in aws or um just in the
cloud in general
knowing your why would be very helpful
as well so yeah really good insights
there
so my next question it's all about you
know some myths that
i've seen around aws certifications so
sometimes you see
in forums and even under my youtube
videos as well i've seen the comments
people ask me
you know does getting this kind of
practitioner certification
mean that i can get a job in aws and so
i really wanted to
get your perspectives on this so you
know what are some myths that you've
seen with aws certifications
and does being aw certified guarantee
your job
yeah that's a good one actually so
that's also a very common misconception
that i've observed
is that getting aws certification or
being aws certified in a particular
domain
would definitely guarantee you a job and
it is a pretty controversial statement
but i would say that it is
largely untrue so a technical
certification on your resume will
probably bring you some brownie points
during the initial resume screening
process and
there are also definitely jobs out there
such as
cloud consultants within the
professional services industry
that will require you to have at least
one to three technical certifications
on the platform of choice during your
application
however according to the interview
process hiring managers
would usually introduce some form of
technical assessment
to ensure that you indeed possess the
technical debt that's required for the
job
and this is where it could get really
dangerous if you have a technical
certification
on your resume but do not have the
necessary knowledge to back that up
and lastly i've had the luxury to meet
many seniors and mentors within the
industry
that are not only experts in the field
of i.t
but even within the ews cloud
even being veterans in the industry they
actually do not hold
any formal certifications however
you know you know you really know what
they are saying and they will know about
the cloud extensively and this goes to
show that having a formal certification
could be a proxy to your expertise but
they might not be
the the only indication for that
technical requirement
therefore as a closing i would say that
an aws certification
will not guarantee you a job but would
definitely help you
in the process of learning about the
cloud and that knowledge
would then eat you in your job search
yeah definitely
very well summarized and i agree with
honestly everything you said
and yeah in my comments when people ask
me that that would be something i sort
of relate to them as well
it doesn't guarantee your job but it
does map out a really good learning
pathway for you to get started with your
cloud learning journey
and so you know talking about the
benefits of
aws certifications uh what are the
benefits in getting adb certified
yeah so my mental model of the benefits
of being
certified on a cloud platform has
changed during my journey
so at the very start i'm going to be
honest um
i assume that getting a certification
would mean that you know you have a lot
better job prospects
um you would be a lot more attractive as
a job seeker
and that frames my intention when going
for my first year certifications
but i've soon learned that the biggest
benefit of being certified
actually lies in the process of studying
for them i feel like they provide a
really good structure
for someone who would like to get good
within a specific domain
for example if you are interested in
cyber security
using the curriculum of the aws security
specialty certification
would be a very good starting point to
be exposed to the different facets of
security within aws
and the actual certification itself upon
passing
simply serves as a bonus and
documentation from that process
and there's also a reason why aws
certifications are only valid for
about three to four years upon passing
is because
we acknowledge that technology will
constantly evolve
and most of the theoretical knowledge
that you learn today
will probably not be as relevant anymore
you know three to four years down the
road
so this reinforced the idea that getting
the certification is one thing
but the value lies in the knowledge and
content that you can pick up from that
journey
exactly yeah definitely agree with that
as well
and especially since in the tech
industry everything is changing so fast
that's also the reason why you know aws
certifications
are only valid for a couple of years the
questions are always changing depending
on the new services that are added
and everything like that as well so good
benefits that you mentioned
with aws certifications so i guess my
final question
is for students who click on this video
and they're interested
in you know also being like you also
passing 12 aws certifications
or 11 now because you know the alexa one
has retired so
you know all 11 certifications what
advice do you have for these students
i have two advice for them and the first
one would be
please don't so
just to go on the side tangent i often
get this question from my friends that
hey glendon
um if you are not interning at aws and
you
actually had to you know fork out your
own money
to go for those certifications where you
actually go for all 12 of them
and my answer to that is i wouldn't
because number one is really expensive
uh each certification ranges from 150 to
200 usd
and if you do the math going for all 12
of them
would means you know going to the
thousands on top of that
i feel like there's some degree of
sub-modularity when going for the
certifications
for example the aws solutions architect
professional certification
would actually cover most of the
curriculum
for associate level certifications and
even the cloud provision as a
certification hence if your intention
is simply to focus on getting the
content
and learning about the cloud then i
would recommend taking
a more frugal approach and go for the
more challenging certifications from the
beginning
however if you do have the luxury to
really go for all 12 of them and my
advice would be to have fun
take them slowly but with intent and be
really consistent with your preparation
the amount of content for those
certifications can get daunting and
overwhelming
but as you spread them across a long
period of time they become a lot more
manageable
finally um this is also a very common
advice from yourself
uh it helps to have hands-on experience
to complement your study process
if possible pick up a side project or
even follow a youtube tutorial
just to see everything in action exactly
there's so many resources out there that
give you that sort of hands-on lab
experience and sometimes you don't have
to be
you know aiming to pass every single
certification to validate that knowledge
a lot of the time it's just you know
doing those free online courses out
there
more for your own understanding and your
own learning so yeah really good call
out there
and yeah for students who do want to
pass those certifications
hands-on labs is really a must so thank
you so much brendan for
sharing your experience today with you
know passing all 12 aws certifications
but we also covered a lot of other
topics including
you know how students should get started
what are the challenges that you face
yeah i really enjoyed having you on the
show today and this is a lot of good
tips that i'll take away as well because
i do eventually want to be able to pass
all 12
um probably not within 12 months but you
know eventually
so really good tips that you mentioned
and i'm sure a lot of the
viewers today would have gained a lot of
insights from that so thank you so much
i'll see you next time
thank you so much for having me you guys